welcome to this video what am I getting
here like to 2,700 sin a row okay maybe
this guy is probably playing better than
the one before okay so um I have played
against this guy earlier maybe this is
paco a [ __ ] he recommended b6 move and
a video series that he produced maybe
some hint that is by ho ok anyway um we
get a fairly standard looking nibbles Oh
type of position do I go Bishop g5 here
hmm this is a bit different than with
castles I believe because g5 is now an
attractive or it's in the position let's
say we know how that are attractive it
is anyway let's go for that no it's not
going to find interesting ok so I'm
playing 92 maybe f3 yeah maybe f3 would
have been more interesting to go for a
40 maybe
yeah I wonder can I go Bishop e2 I will
he take G to alex campbell there i don't
want to go every year be sure to g2 yeah
ok I'm he's taking it probably am yeah
correct decision but now i'm committed
to do to do something against this king
um yeah I mean it's not like this is
completely zero compensation it's always
a little bit of something if you have
the g file open but it's not a correct
sacrifice probably i-94 might be a
knight now the screen g7 made okay I
always have to keep in mind to those
ideas so I'm going to double their
hundreds on the G file with King 2 h8 he
has prepared rook g8
oh yeah well I'm not threatening
anything what I can try it's like rook
h3 Bishop g5 and then trying to
sacrifice on age six when there is some
pressure Bishop to b6 what is the idea
and not sure I'm going with this
straightforward plan that I've mentioned
five okay so probably here I need the
bishop on that diagonal and then Bishop
g5 will threaten bishop age 6 okay so is
getting out of that pin hmm
my queen this is an issue my queen is
not really participating that much into
the attack I wonder maybe here and queen
bee three my queen has to be involved
otherwise i'm not going to get anywhere
here the Queen was on the long diagonal
I but after a five this is not so much
of an issue anymore Queen to f5 this
would be cool let's do this um yeah but
back to see three
trying to do something on the diagonal
and ok
this is now again threatening bishop age
six
okay snide f3 a move that's a possible
move now maybe do this not h 4f five or
something some clock is ticking down all
right now it's clear that this is a
pretty cool attack but still has to be
yes we played it's not like it's an easy
win or something at least not for me
yeah right f5 fun or is there a better
move Bishop Bishop age 60 already it's
very very very dangerous Bishop h6 rook
age 696 check look cheeks look g6 as no
made them down close but there's no made
okay let's do this and hope for the best
ever six not that I didn't expect well I
can sacrifice now I come on check
it is really dangerous how do you defend
that now 96 that's a huge fork tough
game probably a couple of mistakes by
both sides that's a huge check but if
you move the Queen am i winning I'm
already winning I mean check where's my
discover check on c6 probably and only
hive and then on c6 something like that
anything better I approach I'm not so
now we're here and then take on c6 or is
there a better one like a high or
something Jack let's do that click here
and now some of my queen should be
involved but ok I'm keeping that piece
for the moment I mean it's not exactly a
bad position
I bet it's equal material right it's not
like I'm up material check I have got 13
seconds ah well yeah okay he defended
that very very strongly it was certainly
lost but he defended that nicely okay
white resigns yeah but come on this is a
win right I don't believe this one bit
check look here isn't that some are
winning no it's not that's amazing so he
ok that is Regina chatted what I did but
ok well let's take stock here for a
moment I mean I really had no time
whatsoever its sequel material but ok
it's a very nice position so night be
three root g six yeah it's mean the
problem is that his nights are terrible
and I have much more space and
everything so it's a huge a strategic
advantage but ok what probably was a bad
idea was this this before move it was
probably a bad idea just bishop at hired
whatever I did later is good this keeps
a big advantage but before it's not
really necessary this is better now yeah
this position is serve is crumbling and
before and so on ok there's a very it
was a very cool game very interesting
game
i I really don't don't think that this
is objectively speaking a great
sacrifice but okay in blitz chess I
think the compensation is probably we
are considerable oh I mean it's it's
it's playable in blitz certainly and the
way I the way it progressed I really had
some some nice play this I went here
yeah I mean it's tough to analyze and
there are many many possibilities and
here computer says equally funny enough
ok I went with this and no Knight f3
yeah I wanted to get the night into the
game this is what the engine suggests it
wants to take with the Jeep on why not
with the night and then Knight f3 is
very strong ok wants to take with that
give swine's an advantage to add stuff
that's very tough one I mean as usual I
spent too much time in that position
yeah here black is winning according to
the computer yeah the engine just wants
to take the bishop but ok it's not an
easy decision for a human player this
here I always have those ideas like
Queenie one and then look h7 those kind
of ideas or look G for gauge for this
kind of thing or queen over here yeah I
was speculating there the concepts it's
not working but it's not easy for a
human to defend but objectively should
have done that and here yeah this is an
interesting thing the engine gives
Bishop h4s stronger that's keeping some
simply keeping the pressure yeah that's
not that certainly quite quite a good
alternative it's not so easy to suggest
a move from black because he's so yeah
somewhat awkwardly placed the injury
wants to go on 85 which is kind of funny
is it really necessary or what what
happens if you play any move I mean I
don't I don't quite see my threat what
is my thread look hg3 and black is
exploding on g7 ok may ok that sets
definitely true we cannot go g five
years hmm I'm on the diagonal with the
Queen and that would have been good then
but ok I couldn't resist to sacrifice
yeah kick here and now queen e eight and
it for at least oh no now the engine
gives a win with Queen d2 what 22 496 on
and switching over probably okay that
wins but that means that Bishop age six
is winning right yeah it is winning so
yeah okay and it was pretty clear that
he I should have good opportunities but
I screwed it up here I mean I already
was down on time quite a bit and okay
this was a good defense okay it's pretty
pointless now to analyze with 19 seconds
on the clock i will use on time the
computer still gives me a total win with
plus two but yeah I spend too much time
for forgetting forgetting that getting
that good position okay well thanks for
watching